so it took us an entire section of this
talk to formulate a problem for distance
based phylogeny construction
but what algorithm should we use to
solve this problem
here's an idea
if we look at the tree that we know fits
our toy distance matrix
we can see that the minimum element of
this matrix corresponds to two leaves
that are next to each other in the tree
right here the smallest element
corresponds to seal and whale and seal
and whale are next to each other in the
tree
we call such leaves neighbors
so formally this means that they share
the same parent node where a parent is
the unique node that a leaf is connected
to
of course more than two leaves could
share the same parent
but the good news is that we can always
find a pair of neighboring leaves in a
tree
now
let's pretend that we don't know the
tree that fits the distance matrix and
see if we can use the fact that seal and
whale are neighbors in order to
reconstruct the tree
the first question that we have is how
to compute the distances that are
represented by the question marks
because the distance between seal and
whale is 2 of course we know that the
sum of the question marks is equal to 2
but that's all we know right now without
using more information from the distance
matrix
so why don't we take a step back
and think about a tree with neighboring
leaves i and j that share a parent m
we're essentially trying to reconstruct
the blue and purple distances
but if k is some other leaf in the tree
we're going to see that the red distance
will help us out
so i want you to notice that red plus
purple
is the distance from i to k
red plus blue is the distance from j to
k
and blue plus purple
is the distance from i to j
i also want you to notice that the
following equation holds
the expression on the right is just a
fancy way of writing dkm
why is this
because the blue terms will cancel out
with the minus sign and the same thing
for the purple terms and then there are
two red terms remaining with the
division by 2.
so i hope you're wondering why would i
write dkm in this weird way
well remember that red plus purple was
the distance from i to k
red plus blue was the distance from j to
k and blue plus purple was the distance
from i to j
and this is important because when we're
working with a distance matrix we don't
know a priori what the weights of the
internal edges are
we just know the distances between
leaves
but the expression on the right side of
this equation
is now written in terms of distances
between leaves so we can substitute a
lowercase d here for an uppercase d
we therefore now have a formula for the
distance from i to its parent node m
which is just the distance from i to k
minus the distance from k to m which we
just derived a formula for
combining terms gives us that the
distance from i to m
is equal to the distance from i to k
plus the distance from i to j
minus the distance from j to k
all divided by two
an analogous formula holds for the
distance from j to m
now please remember here that
our choice of k was completely arbitrary
it was just any leaf other than the
neighboring leaves i and j
so if you know that i and j are
neighbors you can compute the distance
from them to their parent just from the
distance matrix alone
so let's take this formula for the
distance from a leaf to its parent and
return to where we were in our attempt
to reconstruct the tree
that fits our toy distance matrix
we know that the sum of the two question
marks right is equal to two
but now we can use our formula
let m denote the parent of neighbors
seal and whale
let's first replace i with seal in our
equation
j is the neighbor of seal right
so let's replace j
with whale
now what about k
you'll remember that i said k could be
any other leaf in the tree that we
choose so we could choose chimp or we
could choose human
let's choose chimp okay we don't know
where chimp is in the tree yet
which is why i'm showing the dashed line
here connecting it to m
now we can just plug in the values from
the distance matrix so the distance from
seal to chimp
is six
the distance from seal to whale
is two
and the distance from whale to chimp is
four
so the distance from seal to its parent
is four divided by two
or two
so now that we know that
we can now fill in that because the the
distance from seal to whale is two and
the distance from cl2 its parent is two
we know that the distance from whale to
m is now automatically equal to zero
the question though is what do we do now
well because we know the distance from
seal to chimp which was six right we
know that from the distance matrix and
we now know that the distance from seal
to m is two we can simply infer that the
distance from chimp to m must be equal
to 4.
similar reasoning tells us that the
distance from m to human wherever human
might be in the tree
is equal to 5.
this allows us to add a new row and
column to the distance matrix
corresponding to m
and because we have essentially already
added seal and whale to the tree we can
now ignore these columns
in fact let's just get rid of them
completely
getting rid of seal and whale entirely
yields a smaller 3x3 matrix so we have
added two neighbors to the tree and
reduced the size of the distance matrix
by one row and column by simply
recomputing the distance from the parent
of these neighbors which we said was m
to the other nodes in the tree
now we just apply the same rule
recursively so note that the minimum
value of the matrix is three
so chimp and human must be neighbors so
let's call their parent a
using the formula that we had before for
the distance from a node to its parent
we're going to have that the distance
from chimp to a is the distance from
chimp to m
plus the distance from chimp to human
minus the distance from human to m
all divided by two
this gives us when we plug in the values
two divided by two
or one
since the distance from chimp to human
is three
we can now conclude that the distance
from human to a must be two
automatically right
and now we can conclude that the
distance from a to m
must be equal to three as well
because we knew that the distance from
chimp to m was equal to four
and we just computed that the distance
from chimp to a was one so the remaining
edge must be three and that's the simple
tree that i showed you before that fits
our original matrix
so the one thing i would like to point
out though
is that it's possible for when we're
reconstructing the tree an internal edge
to have weight zero
right we didn't know that
this edge had to have weight three we
could have had some other distance
matrix where it had weight zero
in this case rather than carrying along
a weight zero internal edge and by
internal edge i mean an edge that
connects two internal nodes
we would simply compress a and m into a
single node
now we don't do this for whale
connected to m because we can't make
whale an internal node of our tree
because it's a present-day species
so before we move on
i'd just like to have you try this
method for yourself so here's a sample
toy 4x4 distance matrix
what's the tree that fits this distance
matrix
if you somehow get stuck along
your way of trying to reconstruct this
i'll see you in the next section